where are you right now where I think
just leaving Scotland we place the phone
back into England I've been paying that
much attention did you how'd you
celebrate yesterday or did you yeah we
are a few drinks if they even had a
couple of the golf club but ma'am we
just stopped near a pub around the
corner from my house and just had a
couple and just had a quiet one are you
are you famous now I don't know man
other though I just say mopey just
having a good time man when when people
start chanting beef you know what was
going through your mind when you started
here in the gallery chanting man i love
it man i absolutely love it and then
yeah it needs a lot to me you know and
tonight it may be pretty speechless this
this week by saturday sunday it was just
crazy and then i remember forever if you
were going to describe how you look to
somebody who has not met you how would
you describe how you look such a
good-looking guy I guess normal bloke
with a beard yes I would have bit of a
belly I guess just that and you got some
hair there too yeah yeah but that's how
you got your name so I people look at
you and probably go you know what you're
you're a hefty guy that's how you got
your nickname but beef has nothing to do
with your size right no no it doesn't
know I sent to my hair my head and who
gave you that nickname one of my good
mates them who's a member of my golf
club we grew up playing junior at all
he's a few years older than me and then
yeah he just said it one day and sort of
told everyone and he just stuck everyone
just started calling me and they like to
be mine and I was out of my told me what
you want all right so then everyone just
i call mep
and yeah just [ __ ] then we need to get a
sponsorship for you though beef yeah
yeah we're like some kind of steak or
something that you know you're going to
be the spokesperson for where hamburgers
or some kind of steak yeah exactly that
be cool like that ah did you get to stay
and watch Stenson and Mickelson finish
no butterfly man I come off and fly my
card and did a few interviews and there
they had babe finish I said I want to
watch the high life I wanna watch the
highlights because I'm sure they will
plan a different golf course oh the way
those two were playing to be that far
ahead of everybody else I mean that was
crazy to watch yes it's unbelievable and
I but I think I heard someone say that
still shut that score you would one like
a hundred and thirty opens with
something like that I think is that true
yeah I think it's he would have won a
hundred and forty British Opens out of
out of 145 I think oh man that is crazy
but I also i was i started off fairly
well after six holes that I looked at
the school board is evident that they
were 54 under manny how did you grow up
playing Gong just there through my bag
we used to Risa can play like the local
like picture in platts unlike hit balls
and one of local fields and then I
joined behind course for Phil effects
when I was nine and yeah just constantly
played it and instead of things doing
homework at school I guess I ended up
playing in the surf on the golf course
more often than my actual oh [ __ ] did
you ever have that moment like were you
ever intimidated playing with these guys
you'd watched on TV yeah I think at the
star license it's an experience thing
and the morning the more you get to know
them and be around them and that and the
more comfortable you go with it I think
if I anything
um you just need to so put yourself up
there and get used to it where's your
next tournament oh I'm not sure I'm
hoping a USPTA but I think they'd they
were doing it after the open i think i'm
not i'm not one hundred percent sure so
I'm trying to wait to hear about that
and obviously am okay now be there oh so
you don't know you don't even know if
you're gonna be able to play in the PGA
I'm not too sure it's usually kept under
dryer I think so a poly check and see if
beef is gonna be in the PGA time I
suppose no he doesn't know oh just just
say what how do you qualify for the PGA
champion well look into it might be cuz
now you're ranked what 90th in the world
Lisa ya think so yeah 99 yeah so as long
as you don't do anything to screw that
up before the PGA you got you should be
pretty good i imagine yeah yeah I think
maybe maybe we'll just petition the PGA
to have you I I think you're going to be
surprised the reaction of Americans if
you get a chance to play in the PGA the
reaction to you when you get here I love
it then I love it and you know the more
love the more love occur at the mall i'm
gonna confess that I are absolutely love
it hey well congrats that was well done
you had fun with it to like you know it
was different to watch somebody who's
playing a tough course in a big
championship like that and you enjoyed
it people could certainly identify with
that so congrats and hopefully we'll see
you stateside perfect thank you for LA
all right thank you Andrew Andrew beef
Johnston the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience